can we start with what you may have
heard i know you couldn't see the
pictures but you heard from
your people on the streets of the
capital who want your government to be
tougher
what would you say to them i think
the message we've already sent is that
we will use
every diplomatic and political option to
pursue
a path at the united nations as well to
show the world
what india has done let's consider what
india has done by this action which is
illegal
illegitimate and unlawful what they have
done
is to fly in the face of security
council resolutions that have been there
on the council's agenda for 70 years 11
security council resolution they have
violated them
they have violated international law
they don't wish to talk to pakistan
to find a peaceful settlement of this
outstanding dispute
and as your new story showed they have
turned
14 million people over 14 million people
in occupied kashmir into prisoners this
is an armed camp
that they have created and this is a
serious situation
which poses a grave threat to peace and
security
in our region i wonder i do i do want to
ask sorry to intro i do want to ask you
about your talks at the u.n
but first just what you were talking
about in reaction to what the people in
islamabad were saying
is it fair to say there's some mixed
messaging coming from pakistan
your prime minister said five day uh
said uh very recently in fact that he
doesn't want war it would be absolutely
disastrous
is what he said in parliament but your
chief of the army
was saying the pakistan army stands
firmly by the kashmiris we are prepared
and will go to any extent
to to fulfill our obligations that
sounds like war is on the table
no war is not on the table pakistan does
not wish to see a conflict pakistan will
not do anything to escalate the
situation
the aggressor and the country that's
escalated the situation and take us
taken us to the edge of the precipice is
india and i think what we will do at the
united nations
is to take up the issue with the
security council after all
the un has outstanding responsibilities
to deal with this issue
there are security council resolutions
as i explained to you earlier
and what we had yesterday was a very
strong statement from the secretary
general of the united nations
which validated these council
resolutions and said
this issue must be resolved according to
the u.n charter
and the u.n charter what is integral in
the u.n charter
is the right of self-determination i
think what's at stake here
is the destiny the future and the lives
of
over 14 million people who've been
turned into hostages
there is huge military presence in
occupied jammu and kashmir
so i think what you will see my country
doing is to take this issue
up at the diplomatic level and use all
political means to ensure
that we get justice for the kashmiri
people i think our message
to the kashmiri people is you're not
alone you will never be alone
we are with you and we will continue to
do whatever we can
to ensure that your plight look tom
ultimately this issue
in the first instance this issue is
about human suffering
it's about the plight of a people who've
been deprived of their liberty for over
70 years
and now they're on the edge of being
deprived of everything else
they cannot leave their homes their
leaders are in have been arrested
they their food shortages and above all
now there is an assault on their very
identity
so pakistan will stand with the people
of kashmir and we will do whatever we
can
to ensure that there is justice you
rightly call out those human rights
abuses and you've just said you know we
are with you the people of kashmir
you highlight their human suffering
correctly but is it slightly
hypocritical given that pakistan was on
a list of countries who praised china's
contribution to international human
rights causes
for what large proportions of the
international community consider
internment in forced labour camps in
xinjiang who are
all of whom are muslims how why are we
changing the narrative why are we
changing the subject well you're called
you're rightly calling you're rightly
calling out human rights abuses
you're rightly human rights abuses the
issue
you should do across the board the issue
is of
international law there are security
council resolutions as i said
there are two reports of the united
nations on human rights violations in
occupied kashmir
we have to keep the focus on a crisis
that is brewing
in our region we don't want this crisis
to spin out of control
we would like the international
community to step up to the plate
to stand on the side of law justice
and fairness and also to deliver on the
pledges that were made to the people of
kashmir by the indian leadership itself
years and years ago indian leaders
pledged and promised a plebiscite
for the people of jammu and kashmir so
that they could freely
decide their destiny so if you believe
in democracy
and if you believe in liberty and if you
believe in human rights
why is it denied to the people of
occupied kashmir i think but you don't
think but you don't think that
those same rights you should stand up
for them for people in other countries
very close to you
in china that's not the issue that's not
the issue under discussion
right now uh what we will be taking up
with the security council
is the issue which is before us before
this crisis
spins out of control okay let me ask you
about that about antonio gutierrez and
the un in general then do you do you
really have confidence
in the un stepping up to the plate
because his statement which was
supportive
of you also said that he recalls the
1972 agreement on bilateral relations
between india and pakistan
which states that the final status of
jammu and kashmir is to be settled by
peaceful means do you think he's
distancing the u.n from a key role in
this with that statement not at all
not at all by validating and referring
to u.n security council resolutions
by also expressing his concern that
these restrictions are going to
exacerbate the human rights situation in
occupied kashmir
we are satisfied with this statement and
we really think
that it will be up to the security
council now to address this issue
it is a major issue it is a major threat
to international peace and security
and also it is an issue of whether we
want to live
in a rules-based international order
where people abide by security council
resolutions
or do we want to live in a world where
countries get up
and you know unilaterally take actions
that pose a threat
to not just their neighbor but to the
whole world actually
can i ask you about the reaction of
muslim majority countries saudi arabia
was part of a statement that was
released but they've refrained from
taking a position there are reports that
your prime minister personally
telephoned the leaders of some muslim
majority states
and there's been a muted reaction indeed
the united arab emirates arab emirates
has praised
india arguing that the revocation of
article 370 will improve social justice
and security are you disappointed
in the reaction of some of your what tom
tom for a start i think you've had a way
somebody's given you very selected
uh press uh reports so the prime
minister hasn't spoken
the prime minister hasn't spoken to any
muslim majority i have just had uh
i've just had a meeting with the saudi
ambassador to the united nations he's
he's expressed his full support for my
country's position here at the u.n
i have been meeting with other muslim
countries here we have had a strong
statement
from the secretary general of the oic
which is the organization of islamic
countries
we are confident that our muslim
brothers and sisters will stand by us
but the question i have to ask
western countries who lecture the whole
world about human rights
what about the human rights of the
people of occupied kashmir
i mean you take up kajals for everyone
else would you like therefore to hear
what would you like
to hear more from the united states and
the united kingdom we we would certainly
like to hear
more from the united kingdom which is
responsible
uh for the dispute in the first place uh
let's not forget
this is something which isn't the
unfinished business
of a colonial era so yes we certainly
would like to hear but you know above
all tom
what we'd like countries to take
positions on is the issue
of the plight of a people who were made
promises
these promises are enshrined in u.n
security council resolutions
those were agreed these are
international documents
they were signed countries signed up to
them so the question we have to ask is
are these security council resolutions
going to be cast aside
and are we going to allow geopolitics to
color
our position on this and i think
ultimately countries will come down on
the side
of justice and of course on the side of
peace because above all i mean the mood
that i find at the u.n
and i can share that with you is one of
shock
and deep concern about the action that
the indian government has taken
my country has not though you don't
sense there's a reluctance to want to
get involved at the u.n
i think countries are being lobbied and
briefed right now
uh all of these diplomacy is a process
it's not an event
and it doesn't take place as a news
story so it takes a while
to get people to be fully briefed so
that know the full picture
plus look at the situation uh on the
ground in occupied german kashmir
what your reporter just you know sent
you a news report
what does that say what that says is
that the curfew
and the restrictions on people's very
movement
is in place what will happen after all
curfews
are not permanent what will happen when
these curfews
come off when they end the anger
of the kashmiri people will be heard
loud and clear
across the world just one fight sorry
we're running slightly we're running
slightly short on time i do just want to
ask you one one final question apologies
for interrupting and um when it comes to
the president of the united states
imran khan seems to have asked him for
some help previously
was that the right decision yes of
course it's the right decision
you know you mentioned the similar
agreement in a bilateral dialogue
when the other country does not want to
be a partner for peace
we then look towards the world and we
look towards mediators we look towards
the united nations
uh we are ready for bilateral
multilateral any format
so long as we can get justice for the
people of occupied jammu and kashmir